e
good
morning I'd like to mention that today
we have the
um First Responders Memorial ceremony
and I hope we'll be able to be finished
break but uh I hope we will be able to
Madam chair yes I'm over here to your
left oh there sorry sorry throwing my
voice early this morning um I did speak
with representative groda and
representative Schmidt and neither of
them are able to attend today they both
send their apologies yes thank you uh I
knew about representative
Pera and representative Lon will
probably be joining us later but we'll
see all right it being 9
o' representative hacken Phillip you
should sit in for representative groa
and representative grassy for
representative
Schmidt and Senator chamley is a
excellent regarding the minutes of the
previous meeting are there
any comments Corrections or other uh
changes want to
approve
second
discussion those in favor I opposed
right thank you very much that's that
Madam chair yes I heard a couple of
seconds on that uh representative Lynn
least okay any uh all right any to be
agenda okay seeing nothing do we have a
motion so moved I'll second that okay
this time seconded by representative
hackin
Phillips and discussion on anything on
the consent
oppos moving right along all right so
Education
um we'll have the staff start the
discussion
then we have some public comment so
there's a conditional approval for this
um Board of Education rule which is on
investigation and disciplinary
proceedings regarding education Co code
of conduct um and I have no further
comments on this proposal um we worked
with the department and and they were
very helpful and um so yeah I have no
uh Julie Shay rules coordinator for the
Department of Ed I don't have anything
further as I said the attorney who um I
was working with on this is not here yet
so I don't know if you would have any
questions call Brian Hawkins and Lauren
shadwick
thank you madam chair uh for the record
U Brian Hawkins government relations
director at Nea New Hampshire uh with me
today um is uh Lauren Chadwick from uh
one of our staff Attorneys at the at NAA
New Hampshire um I did send in some
written comments that um addressed the
final proposal uh and those were
included uh by the staff in in your
packet
uh and so what I wanted to just um speak
to today is uh in light of the request
for conditional approval what sort of
remains for us uh as concerns based off
of what uh what we submitted before U so
uh first um I'd like to say we
appreciate the comments made by uh the
jail car attorneys that um overlapped
with some of our concerns and also the
changes that were made in response uh to
those recommendations by the Department
of
Education um what remains for us is uh
still concerns regarding Ed 5111
C1 um uh in the conditional approval
request uh the language of a summation
of the facts we we believe does not
provide sufficient um due process
notification um we think the language
inherently allows for what we explained
in our previous correspondence is
investigation notification letters that
lack uh specific facts as applied to the
code of conduct provision um explaining
to a credential holder the basis for
that uh initiation of the investigation
so we we would suggest that uh there is
stronger language uh here that uh
notifications so that notifications
satisfy due process needs while also
providing some cons consistency as to
how these
notifications uh are structured um going
forward so that those are consistent
regardless of who is occupying positions
or in the in the department um and then
secondly um we still have uh concerns
around the uh Ed
51101 um H through J uh some of this was
addressed so we appreciate the fact that
uh the amendment changed um back from
from May to shall uh about the
requirement that the department um
create uh issue a report for the uh
credential holder um but the fact that
it still contains um the provision
choose that the department can choose
between creating their own report an
investigation or using the school
districts uh is is still concerning for
us in our comments to the state board
and in our email to jel car we we
commented previously on why we feel this
is an issue in our view um and contrary
to legislative intent um we have no
issue with a department using facts
obtained by a local school district to
inform their investigation but it is uh
the department that is supposed to
handle their investigations and it's the
department that ought to be generating
um the report that that is true in the
language that exists currently um the
department uh May H uh state that the
this uh language helps uh uh cure our
concerns because uh if the department
adopts the school districts report um
the language states that it would
provide a summary statement to the
credential holder about uh those facts
uh
substantive uh those fact that those
facts substantiate a violation of the
code of conduct however we're concerned
that the summary statement language in
there is still uh too General and that
would result in statement that are
either vague or unspecific and therefore
um not substandard for the requirements
under the administrative procedures act
um we outlined in our email commenting
on the state board's final proposal uh
to permit um the department to again
pick either to whether to create their
own report or rely on the employment
report um and we feel that does not
provide the employee with a clear
process nor does it require the
department to handle its own
investigations as I said and uh issue
its own findings and code of conduct
sanction recommendations based on those
findings independent of the employment
matter that was uh in the uh employer
report um and it does not provide a
consistent standard on which to make
those decisions if the department has
essentially unfettered discretion to
rely on different types of
Investigations on a case-by Case basis
um so and we feel that the legislature
should not allow the department to
codify language such as this um that
makes the application of the rules
inherently right for inconsistent
application so in concl uh in closing uh
we appreciate the time of the committee
uh for in the hearing today um the time
of uh the department and the uh jail car
attorneys for looking at our critiques
um you know and uh we hope that sh car
will urge the department and the State
Board to address these remaining uh
issues that we are bringing before you
today happy to try and answer any
questions the committee has thank you
questions don't see any thank you very
much thank you I believe the uh
good morning for the record my name is
Diana Fenton I'm an attorney with the
Department of Education I'm ha happy to
answer any questions as it pertains to
the uh 511 rules that are before you for
consideration in short summary uh the
511 rules are the infrastructure by
which the department administers the
code of conduct the code of conduct uh
was passed in late 2018 early 2019 and
the 511s are really what bring that
document to life uh so these revised
rules were based on the previous uh
original
511s those original 511s we tried to
create that infrastructure so that we
gave proper notice to credential holders
um and gave the department the ability
to fully
investigate since that time we had the
opportunity to figure out what works and
what needed to be revised and the five
Els that are before you today for your
consideration are really um a
culmination of that culmination of the
Department's experience listening to our
stakeholders from just practical
experience of of implementing these
cases working with the
field and working with the Union um both
the school boards Association and Nea
gave really great feedback the
department was not able to incorporate
all of nea's feedback some of it was not
feasible so for example um one of the
suggestions was to notify every
credential holder whose name is brought
to the attention of the department
that's simply not feasible every day the
department receives n calls and comments
and emails about possible educator
misconduct some of it falls within our
purview some of it does not some of it
we refer back to the district and it's
simply not feasible for us to notify
every single educator who is brought to
our
attention that would simply grind the
department to a halt but there were
other areas such as the report um that
the union had a really good point and
the department did the best it could to
incorporate that so I'll bring it to
your attention that um yes the
department we work with the field we
work with our stakeholders with our
partners and it is the district in most
instances of educator misconduct that
takes the lead on an inves ation because
it is happening in their school it is
happening with their employee and they
have the resources to do that
investigation in fact it is within their
purview they have an obligation to do
that investigation and it makes more
sense for an individual District to do
that than it does for the Department to
come in as an
outsider and and do this
investigation however the union had a
really good point and that was the
school district is doing this
investigation for purposes of
employment and now the department wants
to take that factual basis and apply it
to the code of conduct and that is why
the compromise solution was to say we
utilize that factual findings in the
district's report and apply it to the
code of conduct and we provide that
summary in how those facts um apply to
the code of
conduct I would also point out that for
the Department to go into to a school
district and do an additional report do
their separate investigation would be
problematic for the sole reason that we
are dealing in large part with
children and we don't want to subject
them to multiple interviews or what have
you so it makes good sense for the
Department to rely on the field our
partners and utilize that
report I'm happy to take any questions
and I thank you for your time and your
consideration of the 511
I thank you I have a question how many
of this sort of
Investigations actually happen per year
whatever I can get you the exact numbers
uh representative um I can tell you that
every week every week without fail
except in the summertime when things do
slow down in the summertime um but every
week the department receives either
emails or calls of concern um now not
all calls and emails warrant in
investigation but everything has to be
looked at we don't have the luxury of
looking the other way because if we do
we might have missed an instance in
which a child is being harmed that being
said a lot of the calls that we get are
employment
matters um and so we will reach out to
the district coordinate with the
district and refer it back but we're
still provid providing that constituent
with the attention to refer it back to
the district to make sure that the issue
is properly
addressed I will also refer you uh
representative Maguire that the
department does maintain an active list
of what we call revoked and suspended
Educators those are Educators who have
had action taken on their credential and
that list is public it is on our website
and every time there's an additional
name that is updated and sent out to the
districts um our partners at the
districts cannot hire those individuals
and so they appreciate getting that
information on a ongoing current basis
and roughly how many names are on that
list historically so it is an ongoing
list there are well over a hundred names
on the list but we break the list into
the most recent of this year and there's
and please don't quote me on this
representative McGuire I'm going to
Ballpark it for you that's F that's all
I'm looking for let's say five five for
this year of revoked and suspended we do
not put people who have had reprimands
that's just a written warning that stays
in our file um their electronic educator
file and it's not
public that seems like a normal
employment type issue
okay any other
questions M sh yes Senator thank you
very much
um you mentioned that it that it's not
feasible to notify every educator that
uh who comes to your attention um at
what point do you notify the educator
thank you for the question that's an
excellent question Senator it's one of
the things that we worked very uh
diligently on with our
511s at some point um when we are
looking into a situation when we have
reason to believe and it's really set
out well in the 511s when we have reason
to believe that there is a a code of
conduct violation that this is a
certified educator right because some
Educators aren't certified right a par
educator might not be certified they
don't have a license from the Department
of Education so there's no action for us
to take and when once we've determined
that it is not that it's more than just
an employment issue that there might be
a violation of the code of conduct and
that this is in fact a certified
educator that it falls clearly within
our jurisdiction then we will place that
educator under investigation and that
really is a term of art it is a term of
art within the department and that is
set forth clearly in the 511s and once
that person is under
investigation we send that individual a
certified letter informing them that
they are in fact under investigation and
the
basis upon which they are placed under
investigation and we list out the
alleged violation and the provision of
the code of conduct that is alleged to
have been violated and a short factual
summary and then we sent send a um copy
of that letter via regular mail to the
employing superintendent and a copy to
the
union you and one more if I might follow
follow please um and I forgive me if I
didn't quite get it but you talked about
a compromise being reached regarding um
investigation using the investigation
done by the uh school department
versus School District versus um your
own can you um
give me a little more detail I may have
just not no no no sure I I appreciate
the the clarity um sometimes I think I'm
clear up here and uh I'm not always
clear I think representative Lynn has
experienced that with me arguing in
court
um when I looked at the feedback from
the Union as I as a we we worked on this
um at the department we looked at all
the comments that we got and the union
was gracious to provide a lot of
different feedback and it didn't go
unnoticed and every time we got feedback
we went back and looked at how we could
make the rules better um and so in one
particular instance it was that idea of
the department relying
exclusively on the school district
report as I said there are reasons for
that namely it is the school district
that employs the individual at issue it
is the school district has that has
access to to people who might be
Witnesses and it is the school district
that has the obligation to investigate
if there's an issue on its
campus um
however the union had a really good
point in that that report is done for
purposes of
employment and a policy violation for
employment might not equate to the code
of conduct and so what the department
proposed to do in the 511s that are
before for you is to take the factual
basis of that school district
report and apply it to the code of
conduct and that's where the summary
report comes in handy right and that's
how we would then apply it to the the
code of conduct I hope that answers your
question thank you yes thank
questions representative hecken
Phillips I uh I'm just taking a look at
the final proposed um page six and this
is really um kind of the area that makes
me most concerned it's
the um section
um f and
g concerning well really an
H um concerning the investigations and
the particularly the words may in
subsection h of rule 51 01 I'm sorry I
think you're looking at the final
proposal and not the conditional
approval oh good okay because in the
conditional approval those have been
changed to Shell great thank you for
your help
okay
okay what it representative Lon um thank
you madam chair thank you for being here
with this information um my question is
just if this process um provides
sufficient protection when the person
who's under investigation for COD of
conduct has a higher position within
there say it's a principal or a
superintendent or somebody else with
more Authority within the district um
does relying on that report um still
that thank you for the question
representative um as always you ask
really good questions um you know the
department the code of conduct is
equally applicable whether it's to a
principal or a superintendent and
historic the department has shown that
to be true the department has taken
action on a
superintendent
um the question of the report this is an
excellent question school districts
sometimes do internal reports where they
would assign it perhaps to a title 9
coordinator or an assistant principal or
or what have you more and more often
however school districts are utilizing
third-party independent investigators in
and really what that translates into is
a law firm now they're not required to
do that but we are seeing that more and
more often and as a matter of best
practice that is typically being
done just because the school district
typically takes the lead on on doing the
investigation and that is
the understandably the correct uh
pathway it doesn't Pro prohibit the
department from taking the lead on doing
an inv investigation and there have been
times where the department has done that
I.E if there is a conflict I can tell
you historically one of the things we've
uh had happen under the code of
conduct that has surprised me is uh
we've had a handful of people over the
past eight or so years come forward to
the department and say you know now I'm
in my 40s but when I was in high school
in New Hampshire I had a relationship
with an educator
and the educator is still working in New
Hampshire Public Schools and in that
instance the department has taken the
lead on the investigation not the school
district and so there are times where
the department would take that lead and
I would imagine if you have that kind of
inherent conflict that the department
would act in that capacity I hope that
answers your question it does thank you
thank you okay
Senator thank you um and thank you again
for um taking this question and I think
you just gave an example that I thought
would I helped to answer some of what um
I was thinking about is you know what
what triggers the department to do its
own so certainly that was a good example
is there anything is it is it that
concrete I've been with the department
since
2015 I I think thinking back and So
based on my
recollection that's been my experience
is that when we've had that those older
cases and you hear about them in the
news um that's when it's not appropriate
for the district to take the lead on
that investigation um and the department
would come in and do that that has been
my
experience I can't think of another
instance um but I I will refer back to
to representative Leon's question where
when you have that inherent conflict
where you can't investigate
yourself right um that would be
something that perhaps the department
would say it's probably best if we were
to to take lead on that but in large
part you know our partners uh at the
district they take these cases just as
seriously as we do make no doubt it's
not just the Department of Education
that feels strongly about child safety
it is the districts that feel strongly
about child safety and so I I feel
comfortable and confident that in large
part the districts would make that
decision to say we need to have a third
party investigator here thank you thank
you ATT and Phillips yeah I think along
the same line of questioning um is there
a you know policy guide or um further
points that you know factors that are
weighed when that determination is made
of whether or not to seek a contract
with an independent investigator
um you know I'm just wondering about the
standardization of that process and
whether or not you know the department
determines to conduct an
investigation through the locality or
through you know its office instead of
using the locality's report I'm just
wondering what are what are the factors
deter determining that and is it is it
like is there a protocol sheet with a
clear decision tree I mean I'm just
wondering H how standard is that process
thank you for the question the short
answer to your question question is is
no there is no decision tree there is no
process the school
districts have their own initiative we
don't govern them we don't micromanage
the school districts the school
districts have the obligation to do to
do a report to do an investigation to
ensure child safety and how they choose
to do that is within their discretion
and their purview um and the department
can certainly work with them and partner
with them but we're not in a position to
to dictate how they would do their
report or what decisions they would make
with
that thank you Mrs chair Madam chair I
am actually was the question was
referring how does the department
determine whether or not it's going to
rely on the district's report of
Investigation versus hiring an
independent contractor or versus
handling the investigation itself is
there a standard standardized procedure
that helps make that determination are
there factors that it weighs I'm just
wondering you know what is that process
and that decision-making process look
like thank you for the
clarification um so in large part again
the the department will rely upon the
report that's done at the local level uh
we do this for a variety of reasons uh
first and foremost it is the district
that has access to the people involved
and um again we are dealing with
children and we don't want to subject
children to multiple interviews we want
to be thoughtful about how that work is
done and so in large part the standard
protocol is if the district does a
report the department will rely upon
that if there are if it is an
insufficient report or if there are
still questions lingering then the
department can go in and ask some
additional questions get some additional
information but first and foremost we
will rely upon the report that the
district
conducts okay Madam ch I just I thought
that the intent of the law was that the
in that the department shall investigate
so I'm a little worried about having a
default Reliance on the locality's
investigation first I don't it doesn't
sound like that aligns with the intent
of the
law thank you are there are there any
other
questions all right is does anyone have
any discussion on the unrepresentative
hacken Phillips comment
you I well I guess I
mean correct me if I'm wrong Miss for
but I I I I I did not interpret what you
were saying or even what the what the
union representative was saying earlier
as meaning that the department just sort
of it gets the report and just sort of
blesses it I assume that you the
department
makes makes some analysis of the report
to make a judgment of its own does this
report uh can can we adopt this report
is it something that we can say we're
comfortable with or not um uh so and if
that's the case then I don't see what
you
know I I don't I don't have any problem
at all with that if the your statement
is accurate yes we look at the report if
we have other information we'll we'll
weigh it all out but yes we look at that
report and see if it's applicable to the
code of conduct and and if I mean if you
came if the if the report was you know
something that you came away with saying
saying wait a minute this is this is
really sloppy or they didn't there's you
know there were aspects of this that the
that the that the local school district
didn't didn't investigate they didn't
interview this person who seemed like an
obvious witness or something like that
then I assume I would assume that you
would say wait wait a minute we're not
this report isn't sufficient we're going
have to do more or we're going to have
to tell the school district to do more
or something like that yes
representative Lynn you were correct not
only do we engage in that practice we
have done that practice historically and
again it comes down to working with our
partners at the district and saying to
them this report is insufficient have
you looked at this additional
information what have you yes everything
you said is correct and I I mean I
understand where representative hackin
ph's point but I it seems to me that if
once once you done that then it really
is the Department's judgment that to say
we we adopt in effect this this uh this
report because we think it's it's it's
been done properly I I I I guess I don't
have any problem with them with the
Department doing
that okay is there a motion
representative GES I just had a further
comment on that you know because I think
the administrative procedure is as
representative harken Philips said said
requires that they do an investigation
and I can understand representative Lynn
you say that you know you get the report
and and you say you know maybe somebody
was missed or something how would they
know unless they did that investigation
and then what and in what area is there
anything in that act that says they can
delegate this responsibility of not
doing an investigation letting somebody
else do it and just taking it ver you
know taking that report and saying well
we just we accept it because we've
looked at it it looks good but without
doing an investigation how how do you
really know that's the thing and I and I
think that's the problem that I have
that they should they should do the
investigation as well because that's
what's required under the the ACT you
know legislation is they requiring
it yeah Madam chair just to build off
that I think
uh you know how do we know the
standardized process of evaluating these
local reports qualify as an adequate
investigation if the attorney present
here today said there's no standardized
procedure for for that so I'm just
having a little trouble there each
district is unique I'm sure
representative Leon I just want to make
one clarification the administrative
procedures act does not require the
department to do an investigation it
statute um thank you madam chair um I I
recognize that that some of my
colleagues have some concerns with this
but I I believe that our school school
districts are working hard to protect
students and to protect the rights of
the Educators as well I recognize that
they may miss something from time to
time but I think that it would be a
pretty big systemic issue if we had to
if we were not trusting the districts
being able to look into these because I
do recognize that occasionally there may
be a pattern where we do find out that
there's a that there's a problem in
these investigations but I think that
would actually become a much larger
issue and I believe that we should trust
our local districts unless we have
unless we have good reason not
to
okay all right does someone have a
motion Senator Ward moves to approve
second sen representative Lynn second
further discussion comments you Senator
chandelly I'm sorry I just I noticed
that Brian Hawkins was raising his hand
and I don't know if that's appropriate
for him to speak or
not it would be just to clarify our uh
uh La CH attorney with NE uh just to
clarify to that point on the Union's
position um and I I think the the
conversation's directly uh centered on
our concern where you have the local
level investigation happening there's
certainly that's happening and they're
doing generally a good good job at that
but the context in which that
investigation's happening is the
employment context so they have an
employment policy that they're looking
at when they're doing that investigation
they're not looking at the code of
conduct and we would argue they don't
have jurisdiction to look at the code of
conduct so that's the report you're
getting and so argument and the rules
contemplate that the um investigation is
done by the doe currently and I think
there's been a practice that the local
school district's report is adopted
however that is the inherent problem
with that it's contemplating
investigations done by the district
because you're looking at a different
set of policies and so that was our Our
concern and now we have a further
concern with the change because now they
can choose which one they want to do
with no standard we don't know which
one's going to happen that's hard for
the practitioner to represent our client
and know are they going to go with the
school district report and we have an
argument with that or are they going to
do their own investigation and why
what's the difference we can't counsil
them on that that's the inherent problem
when you actually start working through
these rules when we can't rely on the
investigation happen at the doe level
and that's the Union's position
mainly uh excuse me
yeah I'm having a hard time thinking of
something that the district would
consider a serious employment issue that
was not covered by the the Educators
code of conduct could you enlighten me
if there is such a thing sure uh there's
many instances where you might have um a
sexual harassment claim or something to
that effect or you could have a uh
physical contact you could have a a
variety of things but they're looking at
District policy they might be looking at
the restraint law but that's that's the
charge that the investigation's on and
then you have the code of conduct a lot
of times that doesn't just mirror the
district policy they're two different
analysis so while one they might overlap
certainly but there has to be an
additional application of the facts to
the code of conduct done by the
department that has jurisdiction over it
could could I I'm I'm you're you're
confusing me even more I can't imagine
that sexual or physical abuse would not
be against both the district policy and
the code of conduct it may it may they
certainly overlap I mean there's but the
the problem is the context that you're
looking at and you can come up with a
variety of examples the employment
context that's what the investigator is
doing it's it's it's within the
employment contact so also the
practitioners that are working with the
the clients are only speaking to the the
job and the termination or something to
that effect we're not looking at the
code of conduct during the investigation
so a if I understand you correctly in
some weird case the school district
could investigate decide someone has
violated their policy and fire them for
Vi violating their policy while the
department says well it doesn't affect
the code of conduct is that correct
there may be instances where something
violates something on the local level
and doesn't violate the code of conduct
but it's also I mean you can certainly
have the report but you can't stand in
the shoes of the local level if you're
not doing the investigation because
there and there there's going to be
instances where errors are made because
you have not done the investigation you
have not talked to the witnesses you
might not know exactly what happened in
that investigation but for reading the
then please yeah you know I I I believe
have to Echo what what the just said I I
can you give me a a specific example of
a situation where some kind of you know
sexual you you use the example of uh
sexual some kind of sexual harassment or
some kind of touching of a student um
can you give me an example of where that
would be something that would violate uh
that that would violate the you know
contractual relationship between the
student I mean between the school and
the teacher uh but not be something that
the department would have jurisdiction
to investigate because I'm I'm as
confused as a chair is I don't quite see
where that could happen no I don't I
don't think that's necessarily what I
was saying so there certainly they have
miror instances but they're two separate
matters so I think a lot of times that
if you want a more concrete example it's
it's more low-level issues so there
might be something in the context of um
you know a teacher speaks to a student
in an appropriate fashion but it's a
more lowlevel very low-level
conversation
just a bit of a boundary issue and and
our argument would be at the local level
that suffices to handle that matter and
it doesn't rise to a level of a code of
conduct violation so they should do
their own investigation they can't just
rely on the lower level it doesn't just
mirror exactly what's going on because
there's two separate analysis of whether
it could be a code of conduct violation
but isn't what but when when you say
investig isn't the isn't the issue
really in that in in the example that
you're giving about you know what you
describe as a lower level a lower level
thing the issue is not the need for an
investigation it's what it's what you
just said it's whether or not the
department should consider this
sufficient you know of sufficient
severity to take some kind of
disciplinary action it's not and so in
in that context I can't understand why
it might not be entirely appropriate for
the for the Department to rely on the on
the factual investigation that was done
by the by The Local District and that's
what we're we're saying in in a way but
the thing is there that that's a
standard practice that we're asking for
right so I don't I don't think I think
the problem is if we have a notice of
Investigation to a credential holder and
then you receive um that the
investigation's complete a day after by
the doe and that's all you receive that
there's been a violation found we would
like to see an investigation done by the
doe or at least notice of what the
application of the code of conduct is to
what the investigation report was done
at the district where there has to be
level isn't that what the rule says that
if they adopt the factual basis it'll
provide a summary statement informing
the viil that it has adopted the factual
basis and how those facts substantiated
a violation of the code of conduct so
you can't just say yes we received the
report and you're reprimanded you have
to say we received the report analyzed
it and these actions as reported by the
district violate the code of conduct in
this way is that the kind of thing that
would be in the
report I've never as a practitioner I've
never received that I've received just a
letter saying it's a violation so that
certainly is a good step we would agree
well that's yeah that's what the rule
says that they'll be doing um so the the
issue is that in your experience that
hasn't happened I have never received a
full report analysis from the doe in a
case well that sounds like something
that they uh are signing up to do by
this revision to the rule representative
ly just to sort of follow up in what
Miss foron was saying I mean
is if the department has to do its own
investigation then you know let's take
the example of the sexual harassment or
sexual assault situation what you're
really saying is after the school
district has interviewed the child or
whatever the department has to do it
again and isn't there really a strong
interest in not having uh children
subjected to multiple interviews uh
about these kind of things I mean I I I
I would think this that there's a strong
interest in in not having to do that
again unless it's necessary I mean I
could certainly see if the school
district really did a very sloppy job
and left things un absolutely I think
you have a very valid point but if the
department looks at it and and and
determines that the school district did
a really good job then to just say well
you you know you have to do it sort of
all over again um I I can I don't see
the reason for that and I can see really
strong reasons why you would not want
that to happen repres
um thank you madam chair um looking at
this it's not only adopting the factual
basis the school district's in
investigative report it also includes a
law enforcement's investigative report
so if we're looking at sexual assault of
a child uh the going through three
processes between the district law
enforcement and the department would
just have a chilling effect on children
reporting this I don't think that's an
and it's an or so it could be the school
district's independent investigative
report or law enforcement report so it's
not an an situation and then where would
be the criteria so I the question is do
we have there is needs to be some level
of some amount of discretion that's
applied on a reasonable basis because
are we going to have a statute are we
going to have the rules specifically
call out when it's when it's relying on
a law enforcement because it's potential
that in a case of of um potential
assault between um even between adults
within the school the law enforcement
may not have decided to to take this up
they may have decided not to the case
then do we just have have a default
where we have to rely on the law
enforcement report um when they've
decided that there's not enough for them
to investigate and then we wouldn't look
at the school district um I I I
recognize the challenges with this and I
see echoes in other areas within our
laws and administrative rules when
especially when children are involved um
but I I see that this is evolving based
upon what we're learning with the code
of conduct and the idea that you know
this may not be the final last answer um
I think is something for us to consider
but I'm still trying to understand how
boundary issues with a student wouldn't
be under the code of conduct when it
says that un unprofessional conduct
should include but not be limited to um
ensuring the safety and well-being of
students um I I I see that the code of
conduct possibly goes broader than the
employment issues but I have a hard time
seeing where an employment issue other
than maybe attendance or calling out for
too many sick days um wouldn't fall
under the code of conduct and I think
that too many sick days or something
else like that um really would be
dismissed as any potential code of
immediately anyone else um just a
clarification on or um or does mean and
it's it's one or two or both you would
have to say one or two not both to to
yes so that if there is a law
enforcement report it will be considered
but I'm sure in many cases there
isn't all right anyone
else all right the motion is to approve
the ru
the amended
uh amended conditional
approval
okay those in favor Hi I hi was opposed
no okay we have two representative
grassy and hacken Phillips voted no and
okay thank you I think that the
department will need to make sure that
those reports do include the information
that the union says is not always there
or they haven't seen because that that
is an important part if you're relying
investigations
okay
right Department of uh environmental
services so this is
20246 it's uh regarding the voluntary
certified salt applicator program um and
the only issue with with this is that it
is a delay in Ru making the laws were
promulgated in 2021 and we are just now
getting rules now and there is a fee in
the rule of $450 uh doar so there this
is a voluntary program but there there
may be questions about how it was
enforced before the worlds yes there are
definitely questions about how it was
enforced
good morning I'm Courtney Lockwood
attorney for the Department of
Environmental Services and good morning
Steve Landry Department of Environmental
supervisor yes so I was I remember with
passing this law and have have you been
issuing these voluntary certifications
since
2021 not for the municipal program yet
so that program is not in place yet
because we haven't had rules so we have
not collected application fees under the
municipal part um we are not going to do
that until these rules are adopted what
other part is there other than Municipal
the municipal was added there's a
commercial part
already so we were collecting fees under
applicators this only includes the M
Municipal ah
okay I don't remember the distinction
but thank you for for
clarifying are there any questions from
the committee repr hack and Phillips um
not a question but just a comment under
the um public comment section for the
definition of a snow
boss uh this was quite humorous to me
when I read it um you know the comment
seems that uh snow boss seems old school
appears negative and less professional
and as a result the department chose to
change the name to the green snow Pro
coordinator I I just want to throw it
out into the universe that I believe
snow boss was totally a positive
connotation and I I'm sad to see its
name go and replac it with to to more
words but um you know if there is some
sort of movement to bring back snow boss
I would be supportive I uh completely
agree with you but it was not a reason
for
objection Green Snow Pro coordinator I'm
sure that the uh
regulated Community still uses the term
Snow
else can I make a motion to approve yes
second any further discussion questions
comments those in favor I oppos
Nursing Madam chair this is an emergency
rule from uh the board of nursing
involves uh LNA lure uh by competency
exam or comparable
education uh a couple of concerns um one
is that the basis for this is
that um there is a imminent Peril to
Public Health or safety due to a
shortage of lnas but I think that's an
ongoing problem that's been around for a
few years um I and I don't don't think
that has changed the big problem is that
when the emergency rule was done it was
based on a set of rules an old set of
rules uh from 2022 since that time
another set of rules had been adopted by
basing on the rules in
2022 uh the emergency rule actually has
the effect of not allowing uh
experienced military medical personnel
or EMTs from using that experience to
fulfill the requirements of an LNA
license uh this was just an oversight by
the board
U and there are other things there is
conflict with uh two that the statute
that uh
requires um military uh medical
experience and trained EMTs from uh
being allowed uh there is also um a
conflict with RSA 3104 because it's
supposed to be the old PLC that's
overseeing this and by using the older
version of the rule it's the board uh
there's also a conflict now uh with one
of the
forms this could be remedied by the
committee petitioning the Board of
Nursing to repeal the emergency Rule and
then if they if the Board of Nursing
felt that there was still an emergency
they could at the same meeting uh adopt
rule from the board good morning Madam
chair my name is Shantel wheeler I am
rules administrator with the office of
professional Li insur and
certification you have to be closer to
the mic not being picked
up better oh yeah and so do you have any
uh issues with us doing as director
moral suggested no issues the board is
meeting next week and I anticipate that
this could be remedied then thank you
I'm I'd like to say I'm very
disappointed that the board is using
a an old ver old version of the rules as
the basis for anything because we have
made a number of changes to statute that
are reflected in those rules and uh I
hope they will use the correct version
this
time we write them any other uh
action
you Department of Safety let's hope we
can get out of here before the bag pipes
start Madam chair yes uh if the
committee wanted to uh request nursing
to repeal the rule then we would there
need to be a motion and a
vote I will so move I'll second okay
those in favor I I opposed okay thank
you very much you've been officially
safety director
moral thank you um this is an emergency
rule regarding um the majority of safc
1800 commercial driver licensing rules
um it appears the basis for emergency is
that the regular rules expired in
mid-February um as I was going through
the emergency rules yesterday in
preparation for the meeting I decided to
do a a look back into the filing history
for safc
1800 uh prior to the emergency rule
there were 10 rule makings uh three of
those simply dealt with amending a few
sections
out of the other seven uh four of the
rules expired two of the others uh two
of the remaining three uh would have
expired but for interim rules adopted
the same day that the rules were expired
pattern
yes you from the Department your your
comments on this good morning Madam
chair members of the committee uh John
morasco director of the DMB attorney
Dave hiltz from Department of Safety
legal unit uh thank you so much for
allowing us to be here today um with
regards to the emergency requests on the
rule set um you know certainly this is
not a position that we want to be in um
you know and so what I will say is I've
testified before this committee before
I've been in the position that I'm in
for uh just over two years now we um
within the division are making
amazing strides with regards to um
administrative process and um making
sure that we're looking at uh our rules
the laws uh our forms and that we're
doing everything uh by the numbers for
purposes of the committee and what we
should be doing um for process within
the agency I will say that um within the
driver Licensing Bureau which is where
this rule Set uh ultimately lives we
have had some supervisory changes there
uh over the past year um and uh so how
do we Rectify this in the future better
oversight I can tell you that I have a
um monthly meet meeting with um
Department of Safety legal we review all
legal requests that are in there often
times um there are rule requests that
are in uh the legal unit request
SharePoint that being said we just
recently established a monthly meeting
at the beginning of the month with
Department of Safety legal we just had
our first one last week we went through
the 28 rule sets that are on the DMV
website uh fortunately we've been heavy
with rule updates over the past two
years with some of our biggest rules
with um title registration driver
licensing uh we just reviewed and and
forwarded the uh motorcycle rider
training program rules the ignition and
the lock device rule set that I've
testified before this committee before
mobile inspection rules uh we just
yesterday went through the Pupil
Transportation rule set um and we're
going to be do doing the same with the
driver's education rule set I say all
that um because it's a partnership
between the DMV and Department of Safety
legal and what we're going to be doing
is at the beginning of every month we
have a standing meeting to review those
28 rule sets we already did there are
only I believe five that are coming up
in 20 uh 25 and 26 um so we we are in a
good position however uh this is
unacceptable and um we uh we will track
it in the future
and have you been issuing uh commercial
driver licenses in the meanwhile yes and
collecting the fees
yes are those fees only in the rule Mr
Hils or are they in the statute they're
in the statute ma'am okay thank you
that's good to
issues well I hope not to see you again
particularly on this because I'm it it
sounds like there's been some serious
lapses in the past on keeping these
rules up to
date you you won't representative okay
thank you you won't represent grassy you
have a comment now okay anyone
else all right thank you very much thank
you thank you is there any other
business that we need to cover just if
the committee wants to cancel its
continued meeting yes please okay unless
someone has an objection we'll do so and